Pro Football Hall of Famer from the
Denver Broncos here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you TD doing well rich I am
doing better for talking to you let's uh
let me let me let me ask you a couple
questions about these Denver Broncos man
let's start off with the fact that that
the the quarterback actually lost the
game in September what do you think
happened in in western New York this
past week yeah you know that was uh that
was a game that they had to sort of look
out for you know you got the Raiders
that they're playing this weekend a lot
of some people thought it was a trap
game and and it's certainly a tough
place to go play but you know when you
watched him the first two games
you know Trevor played almost flawless I
began a few mistakes I in the game but
he played well enough to keep that team
obviously into the game they ran the
ball well and all the things that they
needed to do they did in that game
including the UH and we're kind of
senseless playing I'm not I don't know
put that on Vaughn but for you to make
that call unsportsmanlike conduct that
he didn't help my rod up was kind of
kind of lame but you know listen they
they got outplayed the whole came to
play and you're the mother credit well I
guess reaching out your hand to an
opponent and then pulling the old
playground psyche you know he didn't
pull his hand away and then you know put
it on the back of his head like he was
brushing his hair back you know he
didn't do exactly that and that is I
guess the actual definition of an
unsportsmanlike more laughing what them
were laugh I do it wasn't like you know
why walked away or deal had this sort of
you know I didn't get to take it all in
context I did look at what he was going
yeah I saw the movie pulled his hand
away but I read lab wire lab and the
rest should have just have a little bit
more judgment as at that point the thing
okay is that was that a malicious move
well he's trying to icon him no um it
was two guys just kind of doing a
friendly thing in my opinion but you
know I'm not out there and when the ref
and I don't know what they're told
there's no penalties on
in the game you think that should have
been the 15-yard Tony for that no
actually I don't
I was just saying that in terms of what
sportsman like in what's not sportsman
like that does not on its face appear
sportsman like but does it raise to the
level of play of a 15-yard penalty in a
fourth quarter of a tight game I would
say no I would say no thousand times but
you know I guess and and that is the
position sometimes that these referees
feel that they should be in which is
unfortunate that they should not feel
that they are they are school monitors
or dance competition judges although
that's it what did you think of Odell
Beckham lifting his right leg oh man
that was out the old with Randy Moss
didn't most do that a few years well he
pulled his pants down he pulled his
pants down
with them even John Randle did who did
something like that but I'm not a fan of
that move not not a fan of I mean I
liked create you know creativity I like
the guys the celebrations I'm all for
that you know but when it borders kind
of you know that kind of lewd act and
I'm not really for that I mean could you
imagine that's the war that's the first
one out of the chute for Odell Beckham
um when we're talking about relaxed
celebrations I thought to myself okay
who are the guys that I really want to
see with the relaxed celebrations
Antonio Brown was one and Adele was
another and I thought to my really is
that the one that you've been thinking
about all season you came up with that
yeah when the fan of that Terrell Davis
here part of Vizio which we'll talk
about in a moment here on the Rich Eisen
show so who is the best team do you
believe in the NFL through three weeks
entering week with the best shot to go
win it all and obviously we're still
we're still we're still marathoning not
sprinting here but what do you got for
me
TD yeah I mean week to week to week you
team that I've seen I mean I guess since
the opening week has been the Chiefs man
they just look like the most complete
team Alex Smith has played pretty darn
good and I think if you had to say
MVP early candidate winner you'd have to
say it's Alex Smith and you know Brady's
always going to be there is balance
practice
it was great against the Saints and
obviously last week misused any play
well so but to me I think Alex Smith and
the Chiefs right now are the most
complete team they're the best team in
football and the minute you say that
they'll go out there and they play the
rescues this weekend I know yeah you
even credit they look real good and how
about the rookie man how about clean huh
he just can't really span they just sued
as if explosive he just has all the
tools we talked about his backs man
having a tube in it and a toolbox and he
plays big and it's net there seems to
bothered at the young man which is a
great trait to have for a young player
so I'm excited about his future
oh yeah but the Chiefs right now I would
say that team what you think well I kind
of I kind of agree but then I look at
what the Falcons have and the Chiefs
don't have that Julio Jones type guy and
when it comes down at comparing the
quarterbacks as much as I do love Alex
Smith maybe this is his breakout year
that he finally does get the kudos he
deserves and maybe heaven forbid on his
behalf a ring with Andy Reid that this
is entirely possible I'm not saying that
but when you've got Matt Ryan and you've
got Julio Jones and they have their own
dynamic running game and they have the
pass rush and these young defenders are
growing up quick it's tough to it's
tough to not take Atlanta right now but
I would say the Chiefs are the best team
in the NFL right now if I get ya know
that's a good argument I can't I can't
just that that I could say to say that
they're things they're not but you know
just no chief to me I just watched him
week the last three weeks man there's
something and I think Alex I don't know
if it's my home's behind them whatever
the case may be there's something that
there's a fire that the witness in this
man he's playing he is it also certainly
helps it again in terms of home Ronnie
hitters in the NFL and the Falcons have
a few of them and this kid Chris
Thompson for Washington and we're gonna
see again on Monday night he certainly
appears to be that as well
homerun hitters hunt and Hill are maybe
right now one to if not to one in that
league and that's got to help an offense
and certainly a quarterback that
supposedly has trouble stretching the
field these guys can just stretch the
field on a one-yard pass or they can be
wide open on an ax on on a nine route or
a wheel route depending whatever the
heck they want to do I mean they're
really mm at defense that's why I really
do like the Chiefs in the AFC but in
terms of hunt I want to ask you this
okay cuz you got hunt on the three no
chiefs you've got Dalvin cook on the two
and one Vikings you've got Alvin Kamara
who is definitely becoming something for
the Saints to figure out and latch on to
why do you think rookie running backs
are having a renaissance here after
Ezekiel Elliott had damn near an MVP
season last year what's happening in the
in the sport that that you could point
to to say about these rook and running
backs TD I think it's I think it's it's
it really goes back to the quarterback
I think the quarterbacks that are you
know they're probably the lack of solid
quarterback play on some of these these
teams I'm some college ranks not
necessarily the pros and so teams are
finding out that they don't the best way
to sort of protect the young quarterback
or even a veteran quarterback is you
gotta have a back I mean you know I know
there's been people say that the backs
are devalued and they don't really have
a place in this game like they used to
but I think I know that if you want to
be a solid team a balanced team that can
do both things and be a
championship-caliber team you've got to
have that balance and we all know that
as a bag you won't really teach it back
to waterfall it's mostly instinct I get
you to pass protection and you know
assignment and all that stuff but it's
the easiest transition from the college
to the pro game and it's always been
that way you know we've always seen in
fact young backs have success coming in
as rookies because it really is just the
guy skills that it doesn't change a lot
of Penn College sort of pain so I think
it's a little bit of that and I think
the teams are recognizing that we've got
to have a back especially be able young
quarterback and to get a lot of pressure
off
him until he can get up to speed it's
always keep you competitive if you got a
good one game and I got a guy was of
those a dual threat at the scene in uh
in hunt and I even even cook it's pretty
much a dual threat so I think that's
what it is rich um it's kind of sick
little how Beck's coming
how does game in solely amazing
hopefully back to here to stay man I
think that's where you gotta have that
but you know me I'm not being biased but
if you don't have a solid back I don't
know how you you're in a conversation
well certainly those that can play three
downs like that understand past
protection is a like four net appears to
be able to do right now as well I mean I
didn't mention four net
I don't even mention Christian McCaffrey
you had a hundred yards receiving this
past week for Carolina and then what
about this year what about this kids
sake want Barkley before we got the
Vizio TD yeah well I saw him last year I
saw him at the in the Rose Bowl
yep and I was wonder if I was watching
him and Anthony land his son with the
Penn State and so I text him I said hey
tell me about this I met them at the
Rose Bowl and I'm watching this young
man run I didn't know him at the time
but he impressed me so much on the field
he was just clearly the best maybe the
best player besides quarterbacks on that
field and that's when you it wasn't it
was amazing and watching Ronny's again I
think he's got a bright future
um I guess he's gonna be probably a top
five pick this year he's got it the
weird look he's gonna go yeah yeah look
good man well I mean certainly a four
net at four and Zeke at four have done
what they've done so far more expecting
for net to continue to improve I mean
why the hell not I mean that's why I'm
saying it's it obviously the Colts don't
need somebody like Donald or Rosen or
Alan
Colts could use somebody like say Kwan
Berkeley to stick neck to Andrew Luck
for ten years that's for damn sure
yeah except with you and can't maybe
[Music]
what's going on with Vizio before I let
you go what are you doing with me well
are you talking about big players and
big plays and explosive plays man so
here's what all fair deals don't bake
this year so every play on 40 or more
yards that results in a touchdown
check the Celtics Vizio is going to
reward a big screen we're talking about
a 50 and M series smart cast display to
a lucky fan
and I have to do is go to Visio dot-com
for slash big plays and and if it's that
simple man your chance to win and uh you
know we've seen a lot of big explosive
players this year and they'll be giving
away a lot of big screens so go there
again vizio comp or slash big place for
your chance to win and that that's
pretty much it man
all right Edie when do I get you in
studio you keep calling me you know that
you know you know you know you got any
time you call it brother that same gets
prioritize you gotta go stake it out
all right Edie well chat soon thanks for
thanks for calling all right you got it
Terrell Davis at Terrell underscore
Davis on Twitter Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that download around please
just if it's a memory thing just delete
other refs
you don't need those apps this app the
Rich Eisen show up you need that